Do you think pancreatic enzymes are good to cycle on and off with our supplementation?
I used to take one six years ago and was wondering if I should go back on one for any
virus tissue.
So pancreatic enzymes are one of the things that so it depends on how you're using the pancreatic
enzymes.
If you're using the pancreatic enzymes to help with digestion or you're using high dose
pancreatic enzymes on an empty stomach to help kill cancer by helping break down the
waist layer around a cancer, it's totally different uses there.
So if a person doesn't have active cancer and they're in remission and they're doing
it really well, could they stop taking high dose pancreatic enzymes for the purpose of
cancer, eating and cancer, sell that?
I'd say yes, totally safe to stop it.
If you're taking pancreatic enzymes for the help of digestion, that is one of the supplements
that I would say you shouldn't close.
You should stay on all of this because we always need help with digestion because gut issues
can be the original source of so many disorders.
Because even though you're eating all organic and you're trying to stay so close to a perfect
diet, there's no such thing as a perfect diet in our environment that you're exposed
to glyphosate, which is an antibiotic that damages your gut, epithelial cells on a daily
basis even if you're eating all organic and you're exposed to chemicals that you're breathing
in, you're exposed to things that damage your gut and put stress on your pancreas and cause
decrease, pancreatic function and decrease pancreatic enzyme production.
Helping digest your food is something you always want to try to stay on top of it.
But if your cancer is in a relative state of remission and you're doing really well, should
you go back on pancreatic enzymes once in a while, there's something wrong with pulsing them
at that point.
So if you're doing high dose, let's say you're taking 5, 10, 15, 20, you're the morning,
it was same in the evening, you know, 30 to 60 minutes away from food, you cannot hurt
yourself with pancreatic enzymes.
So enzymes are building blocks of everything in your body.
So I would say you're fine in doing that, probably be bicycle to do that.
In your store, you have a few different kinds, any recommendations.
So again, are you talking about using it for digestion or are you talking about using high
dose for cancer?
So if you're talking about using them, high dose for cancer and pulsing them, there's one
set, Dr. Gonzalez used are the allergy research pancreatic pork enzymes.
Are those the best ones?
No, but some people will be stuck and be faithful to what Dr. Gonzalez taught and understand
Dr. Gonzalez used those because that's what Dr. Kelly, William Kelly could get at the time.
And Dr. William Kelly, who really put pancreatic enzyme therapy on the map, who he got it,
that information from Dr. Bard, Dr. Bard was well dead with Lord Dr. Kelly, but that information
and he helped cure his own cancer, liver cancer with high dose pancreatic enzymes, the only
ones that were on the market at the time for those pancreatic pork enzymes.
So he used him and she actually had allergy research, make them for him for years to use
on patients and it was quite successful.
They're great enzymes, they're great.
The negative is you have to take a lot of them to get the same dosage as you can get in
some of the other ones.
So Dr. William Kelly and Dr. Gonzalez, who was Dr. William Kelly's protege was using upwards
75 to 100 of those in the morning, I have to stomach and 75 to 100 in the evening when I have
to stomach.
It's a lot of pills to swallow, so the bottles come in a bottle of like 720 cancers.
I don't think they're the best ones to use now.
I think the best ones that we have are either the digestimes plus from U.S. enzymes, then
you can take far less of them, or the pancreatic ultra 10x ultra from professional formulas.
Those are the two best ones we have right now, and you can take far less.
So if you want to take 10 in the morning and 10 at night and do that for, you know, a month
and then go off of it for three months and do that again for a month and go off with the three months.
We're doing it for a week and off and for a couple of something like that.
I'll see that that way.
That would be the way to go.
Digestimes plus from U.S. enzymes, I hate their name because they have another one digestimes
and labels look very similar and the colors look very similar, very bad marketing digestimes
plus from U.S. enzymes, or from professional formulas that pancreatic 10x ultra 10x ultra from professional formulas.